[Musique]
quelle province compte le plus grand
nombre de producteurs de cannabis
l'Ontario on trouve là-bas plus de 150
titulaires actifs de licence pour
produire du cannabis à l'intérieur la
Colombie Britannique et le Québec
suivent ensuite on peut également
produire du cannabis en champ ce qui est
beaucoup moins coûteux mais comme le
climat ici ne permet qu'une seule
floraison par année et que les plantes
sont mieux protégées dans une serre ou
un bâtiment la majorité des producteurs
optent pour la culture à l'intérieur en
2021 au Canada les ventes de cannabis en
magasin ont atteint 3,2 milliards de
dollars mais pour les producteurs les
défis notamment horticole demeure grand
pendant longtemps le caractère illégal
de la culture du cannabis à freiner la
recherche et le partage d'informations
encore aujourd'hui il existe peu de
données sur les meilleures façons de
faire pousser cette plante et d'en
extraire les composés recherchés